and unlike leonard fournette who was
quickly gobbled up by the buccaneers
earl thomas cut a week and a half ago by
the baltimore ravens still available
still on the market there are so many
people who think he's a top 10 safety as
chris has said all along if he was
somebody would have already signed him
by now the fact that he's still
available shows that uh something's
missing rodney what are your thoughts on
the fact that earl thomas a guy who may
be a hall of famer when it's all said
and done who knows that he's still
available right now to be signed by
anyone
well i think i see a lot of bitterness
and frustration from earl thomas he's 30
years old mike and you know i agree with
chris he's no longer a top 10 safety i
can name 10 safeties i could probably
name 12 safeties i think is better than
earl thomas and the i think the second
thing too is you know as a veteran
player when you're sitting down and
you're watching yourself on tape it's
frustrating because you see yourself not
being able to make those plays you see
yourself slowing down you can't get from
a to b like you used to so i think
that's part of earl's frustration and my
big question is if earl was a teammate
of mine could i trust him you know you
saw what he did to pete carroll gave him
the middle finger he punched a teammate
you know when you bring in players when
you bring in veteran players you
generally want them to add to the locker
room you don't want them taken away from
the locker room so at this point i don't
know what type of teammate earl thomas
would truly be
yeah so you know i've seen this happen
too throughout you know the nfl career
legends nfl awesome players who
the ego won't let them
tell themselves that hey maybe i'm not
quite the same player i used to be
but yet i hold myself in the locker room
in regards as i'm still the man and like
a hall of famer and i'm a pro bowler and
i i'm going to tell everybody what to do
because i've been there and done that
and that will piss off a locker room and
a team when a player acts in that way
and i just again i don't know all the
facts but to me that's kind of the way
it seems like earl thomas has carried
himself a little bit do you agree with
that at least rodney
yeah you know you look you look at earl
too and you saw some things last year
and you saw him miss a lot of open field
tackles you saw
in a playoffs shove him and push him and
bully him out of out of bounds you're
like man this is not the same earl
thomas that we're used to seeing um but
i think if you know if you're talking
about the dallas cowboys i would say
that's a good fit for earl simply
because i think he's a heck of a lot
better than haha clinton dicks i just
don't think haha clinton dicks is that
dude at the safety position i think they
can definitely upgrade woodrow thomas
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports